from the Franklin Roosevelt
administration to the current White
House the event hosted by politics and
prose in Washington DC is 50 minutes
okay good evening everyone and welcome
to politics and prose we can get started
I am Ike Jarrett on oh and I'm the
events coordinator here at the bookstore
and on behalf of the owners Barbara and
Carla and the staff here I just want to
thank you for coming in for joining us
this evening and tonight we welcome
Robert challenger two to politics and
prose so we're glad you could be here
for it and we're glad to have Robert for
his new book White House ghosts
Robert is deputy assistant managing
editor opinion at US News and World
Report a job he just took on about a
week ago so he's new to that and he's
you know first stop on his book tour is
tonight so he's got a busy couple busy
things going on right now
so he was formerly political editor of
the insider publication the hill in a
Washington correspondent for The Boston
Globe he also teaches political
journalism at BU at the Washington
journalism Center so again he's here for
for his new book White House ghosts
think of a memoral a memorable line from
a president over the past century and it
probably conjures up a distinct image or
voice or both but behind that voice
behind each word is the work of a
speechwriter holding up a speech
sometimes in fact holding up the
President himself and Robert Schlesinger
covers these speech writers in his new
book it's got unprecedented scope
covering administration's from FDR to
the current Bush administration but the
book also succeeds in its focus focusing
on the unique relationships between
particular presidents and speech writers
and you know unique relationships
between both camps and these speech
writers very towering figures often
little-known or or not receiving you
know much credit for their work book
also reveals the the evolution of many
specific speeches over time so over what
is now the past century with those
administrations
and while the craft and style of the
presidential speech has risen with a
change in medium from radio to TV to
Internet the speechwriter has been a
staple of our presidential history and I
think that's covered in this book it's
it's illuminating it's funny and the
stories that come across and it's also
you know a great piece of American
history so tremendous research is is put
into this book and I'd say also personal
to Robert of course probably looking
back on his father's work being a
speechwriter for JFK so altogether a
terrific book Robert will talk about it
for about 20 minutes or so then we'll
open up for questions we ask that you
get to our audience microphone here in
the center and keeps the talk audible
and we're recording tonight so thanks
again for being here thanks for for
joining us please help me welcome to
politics and prose Robert Lawson
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening thank you all for coming
I'm delighted to have such a great
turnout and I didn't even have to wear
my Pope costume you know whenever you
undertake to write a political history
politics and prose is sort of one of the
benchmarks of success that that you look
at so to be able to launch the book from
here as a real treat so I'll get right
into it
the year was 1940 Franklin Roosevelt was
in the White House work on the speeches
generally took place after the regular
workday a reflection of the informality
retained even through the war years
perhaps a half-dozen evenings a month
the writers gathered in the Oval Office
at the cocktail hour well the president
mixed ranks and held court he displayed
more enthusiasm as a bartender than
skill his bourbon old fashions were
first-rate but his martinis with two
kinds of vermouth and occasionally
absinthe were less well received dinner
was served at 7:45 and only afterward
with the real work commenced Roosevelt
sat on a couch near the fireplace in his
office feet propped up in a custom stool
he often pulled from his pockets little
scraps of paper in which he'd written
down ideas phrases
points to make a president would retire
of around 11
the speechwriter has then retreated to
the Cabinet Room to finish the draft and
usually another White House
stenographers security guards and the
kitchen staff will quickly became used
used to the odd hours these late work
nights often involved plates of
sandwiches pots of coffee bottles of
soda of beer and bourbon Rosenman drank
coca-cola and coffee to keep himself up
sure wouldn't Hopkins insisted that
bourbon had the same effect for them
Rosenman was Judge Samuel Rosenman who
had first met FDR in 1928 clean-shaven
and slightly pump slightly plump
Rosenman had a fastidious appearance
that reflected an ordered mind he was a
neat man a David Ginsberg told me he
knew where he wanted he knew where
things were and knew what he wanted sure
what was Robert Emmet Sherwood the
parietal surprise when it prize-winning
playwright pro-british
activist and bon vivant and Hopkins was
of course Harry Hopkins the president's
close aide whose bluntness once prompted
Winston Churchill to tell them that
after the war the British would give him
a title a noble title he would be Lord
root of the matter
Lashley had 60 some-odd years george w
bush was in his first term in the White
House speech Jack speech sessions did
not take place over cocktails instead
speech writers were expected to be at
their desks at 7:00 a.m. each morning
because that was when the president
might call with comments or questions
about the speeches of the speech for the
day the speech writing staff had grown
in intervening decades but at its core
was again a trio of speech writers a
deeply religious man Michael Gerson had
neatly combed hair that exposed a high
forehead in circular glasses that gave
him the look as one reporter put it of
an owl
Matthew Scully was a passionate believer
in animal welfare who kept a ziploc bag
of peanuts on his desk in me in his
office he would feed them to the
squirrels on the White House lawn
rounding out the trio was John McConnell
technically Vice President Cheney
speechwriter
a square-jawed Wisconsin native with a
flair for ritual phrasing Bush called
them the troika instead of late nights
in the Cabinet Room the three men would
work long hours in the Connells office
amid water bottles coffee stand papers
and bits of food McConnell who kept a
supply of Wet Ones towelettes in his
desk endure the chaos with good humor I
give these two examples as a way to to
set the parameters of this book and this
discussion demonstrate that things
evolved but also some things remain
similar in the next little while I want
to bring you through that through this
history touching briefly on four of our
modern presidents though I should note
that white house ghosts covers all the
presidents from FDR through Bush 43 I
would like to I hope to eliminate
something for you about the presidents
about the importance of of how they use
the bully pulpit and not incidentally I
hope to get you to read White House
ghosts few presidents are better to
better remembered for their eloquence
than John F Kennedy Kennedy met Ted
Sorensen in January 1953 when he
interviewed him for a staff position
Sorensen of Lincoln Nebraska was not an
obvious match for John F Kennedy of
Brookline and Hannah sport Massachusetts
Palm Beach Florida and Washington DC JFK
was best known for his good looks and
the amount of his family's money that
had gone into his Senate race and his
liberal credentials were questionable
Sorensen was quote not a Harvard man or
an Easterner or an Easterner or a
Catholic or an Irishman or a hereditary
Democrat or a political Midler or coach
culturally sophisticated or rich or an
aristocrat or an urbanite or an
intellectual dilettante or widely
traveled or weak on the civil liberty
side or primarily interested in why
England slept type foreign policy or
master the Ivy League casual style or
anything at all of a playboy William Lee
Miller home state friends wrote he was
instead insofar as these things have
opposites somewhere near the opposite of
all of them but Kennedy hired him for
three and a half years preceding the
1960 presidential election of the two
men traveled through all 50 states
collecting delegates another
Clio use I don't know if they were
pregnant pledge delegates or
super-delegates Sorenson built up a card
file of political contacts that reached
30,000 names asked in 2006 how a middle
class Nebraska Unitarian came to know a
New England of money New England
Catholics so well Sorenson pointed to
the days spent in airplanes hotel rooms
cars traversing the nation those three
and a half years of travel traveling the
country together made an enormous
difference he said there were all kinds
of press stories some of them
exaggerations about how I was inside his
mind could finish his sentences knew
what he was going to what its thinking
before he said it well I think maybe
there's something to that that's a
tremendous advantage for a speechwriter
to know that is how his mind bosses mind
works as well as I did their bond was
well known around town when Jack when
Jack is wounded Ted bleeds once one
person told the New York Times in 1916
Kennedy himself used a different blood
metaphor saying that Sorenson was his
intellectual blood bank the speech
writing process remained consistent from
the Senate to the campaign trail to the
White House having gotten Kennedy's
Direction on a speech Sorenson would
prepare a draft speeches were not to
exceed 20 minutes quote words were
regarded as tools of precision to be
chosen and applied with a craftsmen's
care to whatever the situation required
Sorensen wrote soft words and phrases
suggest perhaps or possible alternatives
for consideration were avoided short
words and clauses were the order with
simplicity and clarity the goal while
some while the summoning trumpets of the
inaugural address of Linc Kennedy in the
public mind with the flower with flowery
prose you generally shunned rhetorical
excess the inaugural was a special
occasion and there was a special tone in
that speech Sorensen said Sorensen
explained it was more elevated language
a self-described idealist without
illusions JFK preferred a cool cerebral
approach and had little use for Florida
expression and complex prose he valued
pungent expressions Arthur Schlesinger
the Kennedy aide historian and might and
later my father
I know didn't he liked alliteration
Sorenson said not solely for reasons of
rhetoric but to reinforce the audience's
recollection of his reasoning his taste
for contrapuntal phrasing never fearing
to negotiate but never negotiating out
of fear Illustrated his dislike of
extreme opinions and options as an
editor Kennedy had an uncertain sense of
structure spelling or grammar but he had
a knack for tightening phraseology and
sharpening thoughts which lazier gave
him a draft of brief remarks for an
April 29th 1962 dinner with Nobel Prize
winners from the Western Hemisphere that
started by doubting whether the White
House had ever seen such a collection of
such a concentration of genius and
achievement Jeannette case scribbled on
his copy quote except when Jefferson was
here who can accept for Jefferson was
here who combined all and then told The
Gathering this is the most extraordinary
collection of talent of human knowledge
that has ever been gathered together at
the White House with the possible
exception of when Thomas Jefferson dined
alone
JFK had clear ideas of how and when to
use the bully pulpit which were brought
into sharp relief in June 1963 he'd find
my place he was skeptical of the power
of exhortation the president's pulpit
might be bully he thought but in order
to be effective the context in which he
spoke had to be correct he liked to
quote Shakespeare Henry the fourth part
1 were in response to own glendower's
boast that I can summon I can call
spirits from the vastly deep Hotspur
replies why so can I so can any man but
did they come when you do call them
On June 11th alabama Governor George
Wallace stood in the doorway of the
university to show his protest at the at
the recently Court decreed integration
less than three hours later the governor
stood aside for Deputy Attorney General
Nick katzenback who had the commander of
the Justice the just federalized Alabama
National Guard at his side the students
were allowed to register in the crisis
was diffused along with the nation
Kennedy had watched the show down at his
with his staff on television with no
crisis at hand Sorensen assumed that
there would be no speech but Kennedy
sense that the time is finally right for
a presidential education of the public
on civil rights followed by new
legislation we better give that civil
rights speech tonight he said around 2
o'clock turning towards Warren
turning in his chair toward Sorensen
more than 40 years later Sorensen still
marveled at his use of the word we with
roughly six hours until air time there
was no speech at 7:40 20 minutes to
airtime the Kennedy brothers retreated
to the old to the Oval Office to outline
an extemporaneous speech in case
Sorensen didn't finish the finish in
time with JFK taking notes in the back
of an envelope and whatever scrap paper
was available Sorensen appeared in the
Oval Office lesson with less than five
minutes to go Kennedy later said to him
I thought for the first time I was going
to have to wing it
the president glanced over the speech
Robert Kennedy suggested that he should
still extemporize parts of the talk a
bold suggests and given the given the
gravity of the speech and the fact that
it was going to be broadcast live the
country faced not a sexual or partisan
issue Kennedy told the nation and while
it had legal dimensions it was broader
than that quote were confronted
primarily with a moral issue he said it
is as old as the scriptures and is as
clear as the American Constitution the
heart of the question is whether all
Americans are afforded are to be
afforded equal rights and equal
opportunities whether we're going to
treat our fellow Americans as we would
want to be treated drawing from the
notes he jotted down with Robert Kennedy
JFK extemporized a new closing to the
speech the address was widely praised as
one of his best but Kennedy remains
skeptical of the power of the rhetorical
presidency
when Schlesinger lauded at the speech to
him Kennedy replied yes and look what
happened to area redevelopment in the
house the next day he was referring to
the surprise defeat of a bill in the
House of Representatives that would have
expanded a program of loans and grants
to economically distressed areas of the
country
he might have summoned high ideals from
the vasty deep he was saying but it had
made little difference in the practical
governance governance of the country
after a pause though he added but of
course I had to give the speech I'm glad
that I did I bring this up not only to
demonstrate that JFK was master of
political rhetoric but also that he
understood its limitations something
that is not well remembered about JFK
these days the JFK Ted Sorensen model is
often cited as with good reason as the
model of presidential collaboration
Ronald Reagan provides a different model
the one that in terms of communication
was also very effective Reagan
understood the importance of
communicating with the public and
especially with his major speeches early
in his first term he would be deeply
engaged in the writing process as was
his long custom Reagan had had his
speech printed out on 19 index cards and
now is the time to speak approached he
made final edits marking up the speech
for ease of reading he drew lines
separating each sentence giving him easy
reference points for pausing and finding
his place when sentences ran from one
card unto the next he would complete it
in block letters in the first card
although he admit and though he'd been
working on the speech with aides for
several months he stood he made 33
last-minute changes to the speech it was
a long and grained process and the fact
that it was his first inaugural address
was no reason to change it and his final
edits in the cards Reagan cut out
extraneous words wrote and wrote in
additions and careful block letters
rearranged words with tangles with with
tangled arrows changing of buying for
the people to for by and of the people I
was buying for by the way it was the way
Lincoln said of his that its Titan
thoughts and smooth transitions and it
was a process he continued as he spoke
making changes even as he delivered his
inaugural address one was substitute
reagan thanked President Carter for the
smooth transfer of power
which he described as the bulwark of our
democracy the original text that had it
as the hallmark of our to be the bulwark
of our Republic shows where my head is I
the original text I described is the
hallmark of our Republic in this present
crisis government is not the solution to
our problems Reagan said government is
the problem this was a rewrite on speech
part number five which read in this
present crisis the government is not the
solution it is the problem Reagan
campaigned on bold conservative themes
brought up but brought moderates into
the White House setting up tension
between the true conservatives the true
believers and the pragmatists nowhere
was that tension more pronounced than
the relations between the senior staff
and the speech writers we considered
ourselves like the Musketeers who are
guarding the Royal jewels said
speechwriter Dana Rohrabacher who met
the senior staff was constantly trying
to basically browbeat us into putting
things into in the speeches that would
moderate the president's stand on this
or that or move him in a direction other
than that which he had stated publicly
you know they called them pragmatists
the pragmatists versus the ideologues as
if we didn't think what we were doing
could work we were just someone who was
interested in some ideology that was not
attached to reality added Rohrabacher
the senior staff viewed the conservative
speech writers as necessary nuisance
we took periodic heat from a fellow
centrist for harbouring so many red-hot
speech writers David Gerken
communications director David Gergen
later wrote their drafts were often
scorching and flares would then go up
around the administration the National
Security Council staff in the State
Department who were particularly
apoplectic at the prospect of Reagan
saying some of the things these drafters
these writers drafted the speech writers
themselves were not simply ideologically
but also personally colorful Rohrabacher
a Californian who had first volunteered
for Reagan in 1966 would walk around the
speech writers offices in cutoff jeans
and flip-flops a suit and tie hanging on
his office door in case of a summons to
the Oval Office on one such occasion he
realized he'd not brought dress shoes
with him to work that day and scrambled
around the executive office building
trying to get the proper attire he
showed up at the Oval Office much to his
colleagues amusement wearing wingtips
that were several sizes too big on
another occasion he brought his guitar
on to Air Force One which did not go
over well with the button-down senior
staff Roy Becker befriended an amazing
array of anti-communist fighters from
places like Afghanistan and Nicaragua
whom he would take to the White House
mess for lunch quote the amusing thing
was watching these guys get cleared into
the building because they'd have two
knives down this sock and bandoliers and
a gun were called Peter Robinson who
joined the speech writing staff in the
second term later in the first term then
we'd go off to the White House mass and
try to make polite conversation you'd
say something like how are things going
he'd say very well last week I
personally killed 12 Soviets oh and
would you like tuna salad Rohrabacher
would be elected to the US Congress in
1988 over the years Reagan speech
writers included the likes of former CBS
reporter Peggy Noonan former Richard
Nixon ghost packet cannon another key
writer was Tony don't pull a Pulitzer
Prize winning former reporter who had
been a disciple of William F Buckley
a proud Irishman he now clumped around
the executive office building and in
cowboy boots and smoked seven or eight
partagas number ten cigars a day
creating what one colleague called an
industrial cigar haze in his office
Dolan was a movement conservative who
you'd communism in the same deeply
moralistic terms that Reagan employed
Tony was able to flush out the moral
dynamics of the battle with
totalitarianism with communism in a way
that nobody else could recall recalled
second term colleague Josh Gilder Tony
had a deep understanding also of the
spiritual dynamics of evil when Reagan
spoke at Westminster in June 1982
Rowland was the principal speechwriter
despite the wishes
senior staffers Reagan did his usual
editing job tightening tightening
crossing out whole paragraphs inserting
pages in his own hand he eliminated the
references to the Soviet Union as a
militaristic Empire and an evil episode
in history his moderate advisors toned
down some of the speeches other hot
rhetoric Reagan had had retained the
assertion that the Soviet Union was
quote the focus of evil unquote in the
world but it was expunged after the
president addressed before the president
addressed the gathered legislatures
legislators at Westminster the end of
the NSC staffers were appalled by the
tone of Dolan's draft they pleaded with
him to change the speech do what we say
one NSC staffer said and then we'll
leave this Willie leave the Soviets
unquote the ash heap of history Oh
replied Dolan what an interesting phrase
can you say can you say it again please
Reagan's speech to Westminster marked a
rhetorical and philosophical high point
for the for his breath for the president
he described the proposal he was making
his quote a plan and a hope for the long
term the march of freedom and democracy
will leave Marx's and Leninism on the
ash heap of history as it has left other
tyrannies which stifle the freedom and
muzzle the self-expression of the people
the following spring when Reagan was
scheduled to address the National
Association of Evangelicals and at
Orlando Florida Dolan again was assigned
the speech he borrowed from earlier two
early drafts the Westminster speech came
back back came the Soviet Union is quote
the focus of evil in the world back came
the lengthy quotation from CS Lewis's
Screwtape Letters about how the greatest
evil in the world is done by cold quiet
bureaucrats who never have to raise
their voices that came the references to
communism as sad and bizarre and a
chapter in human history whose last
pages and even now being written and
most important back came the Empire
concept couched this time in terms that
were more arch the nuclear freeze
movement the speech said incorrectly
labeled both sides in the Cold War
equally at fault ignoring quote the fact
of history and the aggressive impulses
of an evil empire when Chiefs betrayed
her arm Bakshi and read the speech he
understood the reaction it was likely to
elicit the state quote the State
Department would have would have
conniption fits he said so I didn't mass
I made a point of not flagging it to
anybody one one senior staffer who did
see it was David Gergen who worried that
it was too strident later Dolan recalled
that he kept getting the speech back
with the evil empire section crossed out
by the people in the West Wing the
speech delivered on March 8th 1983 drew
numerous tearing interruptions and a
quickly garden garnered national
attention with the New York Times giving
it front-page coverage under the covers
this wasn't good merely good luck Don
and called the New York Times reporter
the night before and given him a heads
up about what was in it it's striking
that virtually all of President Reagan's
best remembered speeches from these two
boys would point to hock to win one for
the Gipper to tear down this wall all
went through this sort of push-pull
between the wordsmiths and the
policymakers but it worked in part
because Reagan was a master with a
written text Bill Clinton was a
different kind of speaker one whose
relationship with the text was more
casual
Clinton speeches were often a dialogue
he could read a crowd and adjust
accordingly the analogy most Clinton
speech writers use as jazz musician the
speech writers were often exasperated
what he did this discarding texts that
he they had toiled over Clinton even
Clinton understood it that it was
frustrating once telling terry edmonds
his last chief speechwriter that it was
just his style and he did it even with
his own writing quote it's when he gets
up there he sees people he sees people
he knows stories come to mind
connections are being made with past
experiences
Edmund said so then he's off he's off
doing his own thing he uses the speech
of course he knows what the policy
nugget is he studied it and he makes
sure he gets it out but he'll do it in
his own style as we all recall the early
days of the Clinton administration were
chaotic take his first foreign policy
address a speech at American University
in February of nineteen
three speechwriter Jeremy Rosner had
joined with the President and other
staffers in the Oval Office to go over
the speech on the day of things were
running late Clinton was not working
from the most recent draft so Rosner
gave the president pages from the
current version the two versions got
jumbled Rosner was panicking during the
campaign he hadn't actually dealt with
Clinton face-to-face then an aide came
in and told Clinton that it was time to
go to American University Clinton said
come on Jeremy get in the limo with me
the motorcade wound along Rock Creek
Parkway pages in the two drafts covered
with Clinton's scribble were everywhere
the president i glass is down on his
nose was editing was editing what was
that line we wanted to add we should
move the section over here which of
these pages is the new draft Rosner was
holding was holding Clinton's cup of
coffee as the car was traveling the
well-worn February Road oh my god he
thought the speech is screwed up we're
about to hit a pothole on a spill coffee
all over the president United States it
occurred to him that it was his son's
third birthday even if he avoided
scalding the president he was sure the
speech was doomed Clinton hadn't
actually engaged in the substance which
was still all over the place he didn't
spill the coffee but watched with some
trepidation as Clinton mounted at the
podium with the jumble of papers told
the crowd an anecdote about how from his
Georgetown days how he dated the
American University girl then he
launched into the speech it was perfect
Roz never called he ad-libbed some
sections he found the key paragraphs and
it was this gorgeous speech much better
than anything we wrote Rosner felt
calmer about the whole process on April
1st when the last minutes the same last
minute seemed seen unfolded Clinton was
scheduled to launch to lunch with
Midshipmen at the Naval Academy in
Annapolis and then speak to the American
Society of newspaper editors later that
day again the NSC had sent in drafts and
gotten their response again Rosner ended
up in the presidential limousine this
time with national security advisor Tony
Lake Clinton held his own coffee this
time clutching it at his teeth as he
rewrote the speech then the car hit a
bump
yes his coffee spilled on Clinton's
shirt oh man he yelled I what am I gonna
do this is my first visit to a military
academy he told the Secret Service to
divert the the the motorcade into
Annapolis so they could stop and buy a
new shirt and the Secret Service
explained was not going to happen
lake offered Clinton the shirt off his
own back the president declined as this
as the national security adviser is much
smaller figure than he was the Secret
Service agents radioed up and down the
motorcade until finally an agent was
found who had a shirt of Clinton's size
and a hastily arranged stuff they rank
they the president put on his shirt like
Jimmy Carter Clinton had not worked with
a speechwriter before he became ran for
president Carter never became
comfortable with ghosts but Clinton
especially after the GOP is 1994 Viktor
Congressional victories learned how to
use speech writers and the bully pulpit
effectively this notion of avoiding the
predecessors mistakes brings me to the
last president however our current chief
executive George W Bush had a front seat
of watching President George HW Bush's
downfall the first the senior President
Bush had discounted the importance of
speech a presidential speech giving
which was a mistake that the junior Bush
was sure not to make Bush stressed Bush
stressed organization in his speeches
logical order he disliked sloppy
transitions it's just words isn't it he
might say take it at he had the ability
John McConnell said to read a speech
through once and grasp its structure and
be able to point out which paragraphs
are out of place Bush's tips could get
mine you do not start sentences with the
word it I like my speeches to be very
clearly structured he told one
speechwriter I think what we need to do
is always at the beginning of his speech
articulate and clearly define the
problem then we should talk about the
principles that we bring to bear to
address the problem what do we believe
then the next part is the policy what
are we proposing what address what
dresses the challenge that reflects the
principles in the policy and do it every
time another significant speechwriter
under President Bush and I will close
with his anecdote was John Gibson who
was a national security speech writer
who had actually had the same job which
was a politically appointed job under
President Clinton going to work on
January 20th 2001 he later told me was
an extremely odd experience I felt like
somebody who's been left on the roof of
the Saigon embassy and all of my friends
gotten on the last helicopter but he was
immediately accepted as part of the bush
team except for the except for the
ideological vertigo he said it was great
he didn't cut his ties with the Clinton
bread when he contributed to Bush his
speech to Congress in September
September 20th 2001 he included the line
that he had that had secretly been sent
to him by his old Clinton boss a guy
named Tom Malinowski when Bush delivered
the line whether we bring enemy bring
our enemies to justice or justice to our
enemies justice will be done neither he
nor anyone or anyone else realized that
it actually come from a Clinton
speechwriter I could go on at much
greater length but I've already violated
the one rule all presidents uniformly
asked with their speech writers and that
is brevity so now I'm going to open this
up to questions if you have any
questions about these or other
presidents these are other speeches or
anything related to White House ghosts
please step to the microphone
[Applause]
are there any instances when
speechwriters influence policy either by
their standing or accidentally that's a
great question and it's actually one of
the themes that I didn't I wasn't able
to get through that get to you today but
I kind of traced throughout white house
ghosts where especially early on when
you look at FDR and someone like Raymond
moly or Sam Rosenman or Harry Hopkins
JFK and Sorenson as I mentioned these
were people that were principally policy
aides who would also write speeches when
you get to something like the Reagan
administration you've had people
literally screaming at the speech
writers condemn those speech writers
they're trying to make policy again so
it kind of is kind of Eden flow as as
the position has evolved under Clinton
in the current Bush it's it has swung
back a little bit where they're much
more integrated into the policy area
sense of how the Bush White House
operates that this guy McConnell that
you're talking about does he go back to
Cheney and say what he thinks of this
and does Cheney do Cheney have a veto
and composition of some of these things
what's your sense there I didn't get the
sense that Cheney was particularly
involved in the speech writing process
or was you know involved in an unusual
way
McConnell was involved because he and
Matthew Scully who's the one of the two
other guys had actually worked together
for vice president Quayle and they'd
written a lot then and so it was just
kind of natural that that he would be
involved in the speech writing as well
in your research the addictive one is a
big figure he was when in the lead-up to
the 1960 presidential campaign Sorenson
who was Kennedy's top aide had a lot of
things to do and said I need help
writing speeches so they sort of ran
through lots and lots of different
people trying to get somebody who could
capture at the Kennedy voice and no one
could did it they went through went
through a couple of dozen people until
they finally came in khan came across
dick Goodwin who some of you might
remember had just been a major player in
the quiz show scandal of the late 1950s
I mean imagine if we all found if some
congressional investigator found out
that American Idol was fixed and so
Goodwin wrote speeches for the for JFK
and the campaign and then this to some
extent in the White House good Sorensen
was was good woods major
Sorensen was Kennedy's major
speechwriter and Goodwin in Sorensen
clash and he eventually left the White
House and then was brought back under
LBJ and was LBJ's principal speechwriter
including the very famous we shall
overcome speech and and up through the
1965 1964 election until like many LBJ
aides he burned out and couldn't take it
anymore and left and never talked to
help EJ again so dick
Goodwin was the thorn in the side of Ted
Sorensen and in one book I read in
particular they said that a long series
of fine that the two would drop to
speech and JFK would use more of the
Goodwin graph than he did of the source
and graphed in the drove Sorensen off
the wall well I don't know exactly if
it's true that that Goodwin was was
sending in competing grasses to Kennedy
but it is definitely true the Ted
Sorensen will be Ted Ted and Dick who
since become friends again were for a
long time not and Ted was a very
territorial writer and he would he would
have occasions whether it was with
Goodwin or with my father Arthur
Schlessinger where he would say you know
I'm glad I'm not writing the speech I'm
just I got so much other other stuff to
do and I'm I'm kind of burned out and
then he'd see the draft from Goodwin or
slaves in here and he would the next day
come in with his own draft because he
just couldn't stand the idea that
someone else was writing the president
speeches he he is he can be very
abrasive let's go to the next question
one quick question and then serious
question and more lighthearted went hard
one sir you can skip straight to the
light-hearted one is the light-hearted
one yeah William Safire talks I think
it's in his book before the fall mhm
well I mean I'm a street writer myself
and so I mean one of the things you hate
is that your principal will be getting
all sorts of advice about your speech
before he or she even has a chance to
read it so south I once hit upon
according to him the stratagem of taking
it down to rosemary woods and riding on
the top of it top secret eyes only at
one time he did that and he was walking
back down the hall I wonder whether you
can verify this
he realized god I've got some number
wrong so he turned around went back
to her office and said can you get that
back to me she said I'm sorry you're not
cleared
III think that stories in the book I the
way he told her to me was that he sent a
speech in and he's written top secret
eyes only and he felt very you know
important that he'd written this on the
page and holidays later he goes to hold
him in the chief of staff and says so am
I gonna get to see the revised version
of the speech and Holderman says sorry I
don't have clearance but I'm very
intrigued by Reagan's first inaugural
because I think it's a I'm not
recognized but I'm I think it's a
brilliant piece of work that brings
together everything that Aristotle said
in is on rhetoric at those logos pathos
and ethos particularly that is who he
are artisanal sir
you are a professional in stained wretch
yes but I mean Aristotle says when it
all gets together when you've got the
logic and the emotion and who the person
is then it's all going to work and
Reagan did that brilliantly in my job in
some way actually it seems to me Obama
did with his speech on race and that is
who he was was right there for everybody
he was someone who came from the West
the first time that the speech was given
from the western part of the White House
he believed in limitlessness american
ism you know that we are special that he
can point to you know all the heroes as
you were as you as you remark in your
book which is a great book by the way
thank you very much as you mark in your
book poor was it sergeant
trucktown yeah it's uh in fact buried
there but in any of that he'd look out
at all these great things and so did
Reagan just have that idea himself or
did people like Jamie Humes or other
people suggested to him like more
serious questions that was the case
where Ken Kosygin who had been a Nixon
speechwriter and had been Reagan's
campaign speech writer had written a
draft and Reagan flying back from
California to Washington or maybe was
from Washington California had bins had
started editing it and it just you
thought it was too flowery he basically
had put it aside and pulled out a yellow
legal pad and just started writing his
own version and reagan's version then
became the speech the basis for the
speech that was given and the the
treptower story he he talked about this
world war one soldier buried in in
Arlington Cemetery and as you said it
was for the first time the inaugural was
being given on the west side of the cat
the west front of the Capitol so you
would look at and you could see all in
Cemetery out beyond the monuments and
and he talked about documents that were
found on trapped trapped as body about
how he he would make every effort and
sacrifice to win when World War one and
keshiki and said well can I see the
documentation for the for the story and
Reagan sort of looked at him heard and
of course it turned out the crypto was
actually not buried in Arlington
Cemetery but was buried in Wisconsin so
they very cleverly did a thing where he
said there are I'm gonna make sure I get
this right the president closed with
Martin crypto he talked about the rows
of markers in Arlington Cemetery which
quote add up only to only a fraction of
the prices that have been paid for our
freedom introducing crypto Reagan and
described him as lying quote under one
such marker though he was careful not to
explicitly place that marker in
Arlington Cemetery Reagan has a sense of
the theater that propels him to tell
stories their most theatrical imposing
manner kiss again told Reagan's
biographer Lou cannon he knew it would
break up the story to say that repto is
buried in Wisconsin other questions
please man don't be sorry
I was a librarian the White House during
Carter and Reagan and often the
speechwriters staff would come in and
ask us to verify all these little
factoids and we had always heard that
Reagan had a box we always the
librarians always envisioned it as being
a shoebox filled with index cards with
little little stories vignettes stories
we thought he read from Reader's Digest
and and then we were asked to always
verify him by his speech writers is that
in fact true or is that another
apocryphal story I I can't say if it's
actually true certainly as I said Reagan
would when he gave speeches he liked to
give speeches on cards and he in in the
1964 presidential campaign he had made
his debut on the national stage by
giving a speech for Barry go on behalf
of Barry Goldwater that sort of was his
political debut and it came to be known
simply as the speech and all of his
speech writers would study it and Reagan
gave variations of it the rest of his
career and so and sometimes he would he
would have the speech on cards and he
would mix them up and just you know he'd
given it so often he was kind of bored
and so he just mix up the cards and give
the speech in a different order please
are you not gonna ask me a Ron Paul
question are you for all Ron Paul
supporters out there it's WW White House
ghosts book calm when president-elect
Ron Paul asks you for advice on how to
structure your speech writing his speech
writing Department what would you tell
him that's a great question because as I
as I said in give me examples of JFK and
of Reagan there are different ways that
you can go about doing this the most
important thing in terms of speech
writing and I think in terms of a
president's success is the part that the
president understands the importance of
public communications and I would point
to to Carter and to the first Bush as
examples of presidents who either never
understood how to use
their speech writers are never
understood how to use the bully pulpit
or the importance of it and and you look
at the effective presidents they
understood the importance of it so the
first thing I would say is you have to
understand the importance of speech
writing and then to the extent that
speech writers can know the president
that is the second most important thing
where they can not simply capture his
voice in fact there's a there's a great
good one quote that talking about the
the famous the famous we shall overcome
speech and then talking about the
writing of it where he talks where he
talks about not simply my job was not
although I had written the speech fully
believed in what I had written and the
document was pure Johnson Goodwin late
later wrote my job is not limited to
guessing what the president might say
exactly might say exactly as he would
express it but to heighten and polish to
illuminate it as it were his inward
believes in natural idiom to attain not
a strained mimicry but an authenticity
of expression I would not have written
the same speech in the same way for
Kennedy or any other politician or for
myself it was by me but it was for and
of Lyndon Johnson
I had carefully studied and come to now
and so I think the ability a president
would be wise to give their speech
writers the ability to to learn in that
way I think if I had to choose the model
of a president and speechwriter it would
have to be Kennedy and Sorensen and and
knowing the boss that well and being
able to help him give give speeches that
were such of such a high quality and so
memorable but they're a lot mean I there
are a lot of them and yes Sorensen is
the obvious one and
and with good reason but there are a lot
of very good speech writers and and some
kind of bad ones as well the importance
of speeches in governing Nixon once said
that presidential power as a matter of
poetry not prose and then he went on to
say I think was an 88 he said you know
Jesse Jackson was a poet and Mario Cuomo
was a poet and Michael Dukakis is a word
processor which nothing is about right
I'm able to keep my enthusiasm for Nixon
under control but I think he was right
about that I wondered about your view
and also I would just say you know you
got great stories in your book I mean
you know you tell about Peter Benchley
and Johnson's one of my favorite is that
those are great stories I heard before
that and and and also the president's
father and the great crack-cocaine
purchase.i he's not on my payroll by the
way no next one it was yeah well I'll
sign the bush Nixon of course had been
deeply affected by understood the power
of television because his career had
been saved in 1952 when he went on
national television to explain that I'm
not going to give back my little dog
checkers and then his career had
apparently been destroyed in 1960 when
he when he went on television and looks
sweaty and unshaven and lost the debate
to Kennedy and so he had a really keen
sense of the importance of speeches and
I think probably spent more time working
on speeches just in terms of cleared the
next three days from my schedule I'm
gonna go to I'm gonna go up to Camp
David and sit by myself and write a
speech than any other modern president
I'll quickly tell the eventually a story
because it's one of my favorites
although of course you gave away the
punchline which was you Peter Benchley
who of course was the author of Jaws was
a Johnson speechwriter and was by all
accounts even his own a terrible
terrible writer when I when I went into
interview one of the Johnson speech
writers and he said he was telling you
about this writer without giving his
name then said you know
then he wrote this book and it wasn't it
wasn't chosen other those other books
were just like wow you know even even
great even
best-selling authors can't can't or you
know sometimes don't do well but there
was one night Johnson or eventually is
in Georgetown at a party and he gets a
phone call from the White House and the
president wants you to come and work on
a speech and he says that doesn't sound
print that doesn't sound very important
all the older tomorrow so Joe Califano
goes in one of Johnson's top the heads
goes into Johnson and explains the
situation in Johnson says we can't have
this firing so Califano calls in
Benchley the next day and says you know
Peter we think he'd be better off we'd
all be better off if you went and worked
for so-and-so and eventually he says Joe
are you firing me he says well I
wouldn't put it in those words but yes
and he says Joe I don't work for you I
work for the president I'm sure if he
wants to fire me he will gets up and
leaves Califano goes and reports this
back to Johnson recalls in Harry
McPherson who was another one of his top
aides was the White House Counsel and
wasn't technically in charge of the
speech writers and says Harry I read
every day and then Washington Post that
Joe Califano is the second most powerful
man in Washington and he can't fire a
speechwriter you run the speech writers
you do it so McPherson has the same
cousin has the same conversation with
with Benchley I don't work for you Harry
I work for the president and and goes
back to his office for the remaining
months of the Johnson administration he
comes into the office every day learns
to play guitar doesn't get another
speech writing assignment no III
I asked Califano and and and McPherson
about this Califano said acknowledge
that Benchley did linger in office in
his office for a few months he didn't
get paid Califano recalled the thing
about security in those days we didn't
take his badge away from him he stayed
around for a couple of months but first
and laughed and and said he didn't
remember that he thought it sounded as
like sort of an exaggeration the the
kicker to the story is that eventually
had been had sort of a guardian angel in
the White House a guy named Robert
Kentner
as a former television newsman and
Johnson and brought in and he had
McPherson had tried to fire Benchley for
incompetence previously in and Kentner
had kept intervening if you've ever read
jaws or seen the movie Jaws the little
boy and the beat gets eaten by the shark
is named kinder so that's that's that's
one of my favorite that's there a lot of
there are a lot of great Johnson stories
not surprisingly very much yeah thank
you thank you Robert thank you all for
being here that's a great way to wrap it
up books are available in the front of
store White House goes come back say
hello have a book signed if you want to
fold up the chairs to clear the space
it'll help thanks again for being here
thanks to Robert you've just watched a
discussion of the book white house
ghosts Roberts lazier teaches political
journalism at Boston University
he's a former Washington correspondent
for the Boston Globe and